danse de huit centièmes le rapport
valade sur l'université a été rendu
public ce matin il s'agit d'un certain
nombre de propositions inspirées par 80
sages qui ont réfléchi sur l'université
de demain parmi ces propositions
certaines que l'on qualifie de
révolutionnaire il s'agit notamment de
l'instauration de ce que l'on pourrait
appeler un sas entre le bac et la fac la
fac comme on l'appelle autrement dit une
période d'adaptation pour préparer les
lycéens à devenir des étudiants à
l'université on appellerait cela des
collèges universitaires et ça pourrait
durer trois ans l'explication de
lorraine cusin
les collèges universitaires regrouperait
toutes les formations de premier cycle
tout bachelier pourrais tu y accéder
structure à taille humaine implantés
dans les villes universitaires ou
décentralisée il serait autonome et
resterez rattaché à de grandes
universités mer l'objectif est de mieux
encadrer les étudiants mieux les
informer pour les empêcher de se
fourvoyer dans des filières ne
correspondant pas à leurs aptitudes bref
éviter la sélection par l'échec
à terme le premier cycle pourrait se
dérouler en trois ans et non plus deux
une première année facultatif serait
consacré à l'orientation et à la remise
à niveau de certains le bac ne permet
plus à tous d' aborder d'emblée les
études supérieures ensuite étudiants en
reste deux possibilités soit préparé un
dogue le menant vers des études longues
traditionnels dans ce cas il pourrait
subir une certaine sélection soit
préparer un diplôme de nouveaux types
plus spécialisés débouchant au bout de
deux ans sur la vie active dans ce cas
pas de sélection
le dispositif paraît simple mais
comporte des risques notamment la trop
grande dispersion de ses collages qui
pourrait à terme perdre tout contact
avec les grands centres universitaires
par ailleurs si le ministre garantit que
les diplômes resteront nationaux seront
ils en fait tous des gal valeur alors je
vous propose mon temps de mise que vous
venez de voir et qui présentait ce
rapport ce matin le but d'un tel projet
de réforme et les principaux points
premier objectif améliorer
l'organisation
des études universitaires tout
particulièrement
l'information et accueil et orientation
des étudiants pendant les première année
d'université d'où cette notion de
connexité a mais qui n'est que la
conséquence de ce premier objectif
améliorer organisations d'étudiants
s'étaient à deuxième objectif fournir un
cadre juridique oui actuellement sous la
gym de deux lois et nos rapports humains
précise que ce ne peut pas durer
troisième objectif fondamental
améliorer la condition des enseignants
d'enseignement supérieur et les
étudiants ne vont plus être en
concurrence négative par rapport à
l'industrie notamment enfin un quatrième
et dernier objectif
la place universitaire et le prestige
elias et française cette
vrai
qu'il n'ya pas une prise en
considération suffisante de ce qu'est de
masques française par rapport à la
nation par rapport à la france elle même
et je souhaite n'est ce pas que la
nation est davantage conscience de ce
qu'est cette université avec nous